(upbeat music)
- I am Vivek, I am a
sophomore at Yale College
studying computer science and
statistics and data science.
I am the co-president
for Yale Code4Good
which is an undergraduate organization
that seeks to have student project teams
with local non-profits and
other community organizations.
And we also host a wide
range of talks, workshops,
hack-a-thons in the intersection
of software development
for a social purpose.
- Hi everyone I am Barkley,
I am a junior at Yale
majoring in statistics and data science
and I am a project lead for Yale STEAM.
We have been cooperating with
the Digital Humanities app
on a lot of project
including Beyond Boundaries,
this whole seminar.
So what we are focusing on is to explore
the cross-boundary of
STEM education and art.
So we have organized quite a
lot of fun activities on campus
like playing around with bubbles
or having a succulent
plant and figure out how
succulent plants can fit into
both the biological aspects
and the artistic aspects
of like expressions.
And we also have an activity on campus
next week on succulents
so if any of you are interested
feel free to join us next Friday.
But today we have a panel
of amazing speakers here
each from a different discipline
and we are really interested to hear
their presentations,
and later after their short presentations,
we're going to open up to the floor
and see if anyone have any more questions.
I guess we'll start from Tiffany.
- That's clearly on, hello.
I'm Tiffany Li and I'm a resident fellow
at the law school's
Information Society Project,
and there I lead an initiative
called the Wikimedia and
Yale Law School Initiative
on Intermediaries and Information.
It's a very long name for
a very simple concept,
which is that I conduct
research and have events
and programming along the
topics of open internet,
open knowledge, open access.
Specifically a lot of my
legal research focuses
on intermediary liability, or
the rules for liability for
platforms, tech platforms, like Facebook,
or Google, or Twitter.
So when I think about
interdisciplinary research
or open knowledge, or new
ways of thinking about
humanities or the social
sciences, a lot of my knowledge
is filtered through my experiences.
And law is not really
what you may think of as a
discipline that is very open
to interdisciplinary research.
We don't have any fun projects
with succulents for example,
I've never seen a project
where, you know, a law school
does something where you
grow a plant or take care of
an animal in order to
learn a principle of law.
But, we do have some new
interdisciplinary work.
And my research center
does some of it already.
So the Information Society
Project does work on
internet and technology law and policy.
And obviously we work a
lot with public policy,
with history, but a lot with
scientific folks as well,
because the technology industry
obviously is very heavily technical.
So we work a lot with
computer science departments,
with data science departments,
with the eye schools
that are popping up all
over the nation right now.
There's a lot of interdisciplinary work.
But specifically my work
is about open internet
and open access.
And when I submitted the
title for my provocation
for this short talk, I
actually meant to write
'the power of open' but I typo-ed it to
'the power I'd open'.
But I thought about it
for a moment, and actually
I think it makes sense too
to think of it in terms of
what sort power would we
try to open up if we could
as people who have knowledge
and who try to put out
knowledge in the world.
So for my work, we think
about open internet,
and threats to open internet
and open speech online.
So this can include
something like, for example,
a government completely
shutting down internet access,
or shutting down or
censoring different websites.
As many of you know, for example,
there's a concept of what
people call The Great Firewall in China,
which is where many websites
are blocked in China,
often it's because they
allow for certain news items
or certain information the government
doesn't want people to know.
But not only that, we also
have threats including
laws that may be very well intentioned,
but may have negative
consequences for open knowledge.
For example, we have a number
of laws in the EU right now
that are trying to
set specific rules for
tech companies regarding
the content that they host online.
Now, traditionally we've
had this history of allowing
tech companies some immunity.
So if they host content that
may be illegal for some reason,
they may be immune for legal
consequences due to some laws
that we have in place.
However, these news laws kind
of get rid of that immunity.
And this makes it so that
if there's content that
is deemed illegal, the company
will have to pay a fine
or face legal consequences.
And the ultimate consequence
of that is that these companies
just tend to over sensor, or block things,
or filter things out before
they even get posted.
And that I think is a negative
consequence, and negative
not just for tech companies
or internet users,
but for the ideas of having
open free speech online
and having open knowledge and
open access to information.
If nothing else, what
I research is, really
how can we further those goals.
How can we further open
expression, free speech,
and the idea of, the lofty idea
of having democratic values
that are fueled by people
who have knowledge and
are able to share knowledge.
So that's specifically
what I'm working on.
But I'm also really
interested in knowing how
the rest of you and
everyone here is able to
kind of push those boundaries
forward and bring knowledge
either to an open space
or to the public or to
include people who may not normally be
included in the conversation.
I think those are what
really interests me in
the themes of today's symposium.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you.
Our next speaker we'd
like to introduce is,
are Alice Kaplan and Christophe Schuwey
from the French department.
They'll be presenting on
mapping post-war networks
in an index for combat from 1944 to 1947.
- Alice Kaplan will join us eventually,
she has been delayed by
her task from being a Chair.
So, our...
So, I think it's quite
timely to have a provocative
round table here about
digital humanities considering
what's going on in the chronicles of
higher education right now.
So, whether it is a network
map, a digital edition,
or a database, digital
humanities are meaningful when
they renew the way we
perceive our objects.
And this is what we are trying
to do in the Combat Project,
use computer to analyze a
famous newspaper that is
simply too big for one brain.
The goal is to challenge
received ideas about networks
and newspapers in post-war France.
So exploring combat, we are
focusing on signed and unsigned
articles published in the
French daily newspaper
Combat from 1944 to 1947.
So that's four years worth of data.
This is a first step in a larger project
called Mapping Post-War Networks.
So what was Combat and why
is it worth mapping, briefly.
Combat was the most
innovative and most admired
daily newspaper in post-war France.
It begins as an underground
resistance newspaper
and a deliberation.
The editors, Albert Camus and Pascal Pia,
assembled a group of young,
forward thinking writers
and intellectuals who reported nationally
and internationally on
politics and culture.
The paper nourished the careers
of many important writers
and thinkers and set a high
standard among all the post-war
newspapers for its style
and intellectual ambitions.
So because of the very
form of this media and
the complexity of the epoch,
historians of the post-war era
mainly studied individual
intellectual trajectories.
The individual careers of
Camus, of Sartre, Beauvoir,
have been tracked down
on a nearly daily basis,
while group biographies
such as Sarah Bakewell,
like the Existentialist Cafe, have woven
their intellectual lives together.
But because of the way this
is shaped, everything was done
on a kind of one to one history, right?
Our Combat index gives us
the opportunity to look at
the same period from
a radically new angle.
Rather than focusing on
star individuals across
the issues of combat, we
explored a network of writers
to understand who wrote for
Combat and how the newspaper
evolved over time in order
to get a different picture
of the post-war France network.
Post-war France is a
period preoccupied with
two ideological models, communism
and American capitalism,
and it is not all clear how
Combat navigated these waters.
When it veered left, when right.
In particular there is
a lot of debate about
to what extent Combat was
influenced by de Gaulle
the leading figure of the
resistance and some historians
think it became Gaullist very quickly,
and others insist it resisted.
By exploring the newspaper
through a network map,
we would like to reshape this idea
by better understanding
the dynamics going on.
So the project started with
PDFs, and thanks to support from
Yale's Digital Humanities
Lab, we are working with a
searchable PDF of a full
collection of Combat
obtained from the French National Library.
And already working with
a full-text searchable PDF
is already doing digital
humanities and is already
changing the way we can work
with this source, right?
So from this base, we begin
to build an index manually.
It includes categories that
are objective enough to
be relevant for a network
graph, and reach enough
to allow us to analyze
the data from many angles.
So, here you can find
some of the categories
we are indexing.
So the technology decides
on what we are doing, right?
The question we are asking and our
perspective on our object, for
the better and for the worst.
Two challenge, for instance.
The first challenge is that
obviously a spreadsheet,
like this, does violence
to historical complexity.
It may seem relatively easy to determine
the nationality of writer,
but let's consider the case of
Jean Malaquais, for instance.
Malaquais, born in Poland,
stateless in France,
finally naturalized
American, write in French,
and won a French literary prize.
He publishes an article
in Combat explaining
American literature to the French.
And it's even harder to generalize about
the political affinity of
the author in a period where
the wrong politics could
send you to a firing squad.
And where the political
affinities which so often between
1944 and 1946, there were
writers who slide from fascism
to communism to anti-communism.
So, what we are trying
to do in these in cases
is to think from the end.
To consider the goal of our analysis.
What set of questions do we
want to ask to this data?
Would it be more relevant to
categorize Malaquais as Polish,
French, or American depending on that?
Well, Malaquais returning
to France, describing Combat
as a French writer with an
expertise in American literature
will be categorized, sorry, as French.
Another challenge is
obviously collecting the data,
and in our case the more data
we have, good data at least,
the more patterns we can see.
And the data entry has
been slow, heroic even,
and we are really grateful
to our collaborators,
Robin Pront, Anita Sosseuir,
Rafael Vegon, Walid Bushakur,
for their contribution.
But in the next phase of
the project we had to find
more money to be able to
digitize, to hire a company
to digitize nearly 3000 pages of Combat,
so that's more than 50,000
articles that will be
then available for analysis.
We will then be able to see this period
from a whole new perspective.
Who participated in this
newspaper, collaborated,
and celebrated then and now as
a flagship of French freedom?
What information did the
Combat journalists gather,
and where did it come from?
So, I'm saying we will be able to do that.
And this has made me my provocative point,
just by digitizing this, just
by building a network map,
digital mapping will not
provide us with answers,
because digital humanities never do.
They help answering the question.
The goal of this network
visualization will be to
provide us, the researchers,
with an interface to delve into
those three years of Combat.
It will allow us to read
those three years of Combat
from a very different angle,
signaling unexpected
connections, phenomenons that
would have never been possible to see into
the text reading Combat in the normal way.
And that will ultimately
invite us to dig into new cases
with a whole new set of questions.
And this is maybe true this interface
that we can do justice to
an extraordinary period of
the French cultural history
and to make visible this
remark by Simone de Beauvoir
in her post-war memoir, and I quote,
"To be twenty or twenty-five
in September 0f '44 seemed
the most fantastic piece of
luck: all roads lay open.
Journalists, writers, budding
film makers, were all arguing,
planning, passionately
deciding, as if their future
depended on no one but themselves."
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- Thank you so much.
For our next speaker we
have Mr. Joseph Zinter,
from Engineering and
Applied Science and CEID.
- So the Center for Engineering,
Innovation, and Design,
much like the digital humanities lab,
is open to all of Yale.
And over the last few years,
we've developed a very
diverse community of people
pursuing a variety of
really, really interesting projects.
What I'd like to do today is just show two
very short videos, one demonstrates
a project that was done
in collaboration with
the department of French,
and the second will be
a collaboration with
the Institute for the
Preservation of Cultural Heritage.
(train horn)
- I think what I wanted
to teach the students is
the importance of close reading,
why is it important to do
close reading in the class
and what does it look
Yeah to close reading in context.
So, when you have this
train you are forced to
look closely at the text, to produce it.
In Zola's text, the train
is a metaphor because Zola
exaggerates the proportion,
but it's also a metaphor
for progress, for history,
for women, because the
train has a woman's name,
for sexuality and desire,
and also for human bestiality.
I would say they are the three
main metaphor or three main
concepts that the train
symbolizes in this text.
We were looking at descriptions,
in French and in English,
from the text and we were
reading those descriptions
to the engineers, and they
were trying to, you know,
retranslate what we were saying
into an object, into code.
So you know, really reading
sentences, art, and aiming at
translating into an object.
And that was really interesting
to me because I remember
Dean Vince was saying that
all this process is a translation.
Zola was translating
the images of trains so
when he was young, then the
text was translated in English
and then this English
text was translated into
a computer program that
ended up printing a 3D train.
- Okay, the next example I'd
like to show was one from our
course Introduction to
Engineering Innovation and Design.
(classical music)
- [Narrator] Michelangelo's
David, strong, youthful,
standing tall throughout the centuries.
But the standing is becoming a problem.
- Over time David has started
tilting forward, and so that's
creating hairline cracks
in the back of its ankles.
The sculpture is probably
in a couple centuries
going to fall over.
- [Narrator] Michelle knows
all about this because
she and her fellow students
built a way to study it
in an introductory engineering class.
- Each group gets assigned
their own project that
helps someone at Yale with
a problem that they have.
- [Narrator] Michelle's
group worked with Yale's
Institute for the Preservation
of Cultural Heritage,
know as the IPCH, which
wanted a way to study
what happens to sculptures
like David over time.
The students built this machine,
which they nicknamed Fred,
and models that mimic
the angle and pressure
of David's ankles.
- Essentially, our design
created a machine that applied
force downward until the models
that we inserted in between
these two plates were compressed
enough where they broke.
- This is the time,
this is the total force,
and we can see it just goes
down as the model cracks.
- [Narrator] David is made of
marble, but the IPCH wants to
study the effects of this
pressure on multiple materials,
so the group also made models
out of concrete and clay.
- It was definitely a really
good experience getting to be
hands on so fast, 'cause
it really let me see
if it was something I wanted to do.
- It's really satisfying
to me, because you see
these students who when they
first showed up they maybe
didn't have any background
in building things and
making things and now they're
doing all this great stuff.
- [Narrator] As for David, well for now,
he's still standing tall.
Hopefully, with the help
of research like this,
he can stay that way.
(classical music)
- Okay, so just two quick
projects to demonstrate
the breadth and diversity of
the type of work that we're doing.
The engineering school
is so proud of its work
with the humanities that
two of its last four
yearly magazines are proudly
displaying these projects,
so thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you.
For our next speaker we'll have
Peter Leonard from the DHLab.
He'll be presenting Every
Pixel on the Sunset Strip:
Ed Ruscha Between Archive and Data Set.
- Terrific, so first
I'm really just curious,
how many people in the
room, raise your hand if
you've heard of Ed Ruscha before.
That's great, that's more than most.
We're really excited to talk today about
a really important pop
artist, a really important
collaboration with the Getty,
and some interesting
work in computer vision.
For those who aren't
familiar with Ed Ruscha,
he comes from Nebraska,
comes to the west coast,
does all sorts of interesting
artistic work, painting,
photography, he's most famous
maybe for the artist's book
Every Building on the
Sunset Strip, which I've put
two pictures of at the very
top of the screen and at
the bottom Ruscha himself
looking at proofs of the book.
It's an enormous, complicated volume,
it's small in some dimensions
then when you fold it out
it's really long, and you can
find copies of this at Yale,
at least there's one in the
Haas Art Special Collection,
I think there's one at the Beinecke too,
I really encourage you to look at
Every Building on the Sunset Strip.
It's an artist's book created
out of an archive that
Ruscha himself built by putting
a camera in a pickup truck
and driving it down the streets
of Los Angeles in the 1960s.
It's really kind of an early
form of Google street view,
in fact Ruscha would
probably claim he invented
the idea of Google street view.
But this is the 1960s,
it's black and white,
and sort of carefully hand assembles this
in a completely pre-digital era.
It's worth pointing out
that Ruscha has continued
to do this work for decades.
There's still vans driving
around the city of Los Angeles
manned by his team putting
these things together.
This archive of photographs
that was built into collections
like Every Building on the Sunset Strip
has recently come to the Getty.
And the Getty Research
Institute put out a call for
researcher projects to
consider how we might think of
Ruscha and his work, not
just in the context of
the couple dozen images that comprise
Every Building on the Sunset
Strip, but the hundreds
of thousands of negatives
that nobody's ever seen
that go into this long,
linear visualization,
this kind of banal, pop
art, vision of the city.
And when the lab applied to
be one of the teams that would
work with collection of hundreds
of thousands of negatives,
we knew that we had a problem on our hands
because Ruscha had already
accomplished perhaps
the most important work
with his photography.
He had created this really
important artist's book,
and we felt in considering
an archive of hundreds of
thousands of pictures that we
really didn't wanna sort of
replicate or create a robotic
version of the artist's book
which already exists in all
sort of special collections.
So we decided to take a
different path, we wanted to
think about building an
urban heatmap of sort of
geospatial visualization
of discreet objects
inside the photography.
And what this meant is we had to get into
the world of semantic
segmentation, of masking out
what's actually in each image.
And so, I'll take you
through our process for this,
but the basic notion to hear is that
this is a step beyond image captioning.
Our cell phones can already
tell us what pictures
we've taken of cats,
that's just a convolutional
neural network that can
provide image captions.
Behind the scenes they actually
know what part of the image
that cat is in in your pictures,
if it's the top or the bottom.
A stage beyond that towards
semantic segmentation
is an example in the
bottom of this screen.
So we have a really complicated image,
there's all sorts of things going on here,
but a masking recurrent
neural network has actually
identified the bicycles
as discreet from the boy
holding out his hand as
discreet from the rider.
This is done all by sort
of computational work,
there's no humans involved at this phase.
And so what we wanted to do was see
would this technique work
on Ed Ruscha's photography?
And so this is an actual negative from
the Getty Research Institute,
taken by Ed Ruscha's team
in the '60s, and you can
see it's the Sunset Strip.
And the algorithm has expertly identified
a Volkswagen Beetle.
Now what's important about this is that
its never seen a Volkswagen
Beetle before, right?
It's been trained on
much more modern cars.
But the convolutional
neural network is capable
of doing this masking, this
semantic segmentation to tell us
exactly where the cars,
and the specific outlines,
not just the bounding boxes.
Now this is actually part of
our idea for this interface,
for building an urban heatmap with really
semantic segmented objects on it.
We've taken the idea of a
car just as our first demo.
As you can see here, what
this might look like,
we're looking at a map of Los
Angeles, and we have kind of
a way of navigating through the city here
and looking where particular items are.
You'll see that in this case
our demonstration is cars,
and if you look at the
very bottom of the screen,
you'll see that we're
actually blurring all of
the photography and only
things that are crisp
are the detected cars at the bottom.
We created this heatmap, or
this sort of visualization
of where automobiles are in the
map, in Rusha's photography,
but we're not trying to
replicate the artist's book.
The interface is inspired by
the aesthetic of this work,
but we really want this to
be about something else.
To be about discovering
the discreet objects
within this archive of
hundred of thousands
of pieces of urban photography.
In addition to finding discreet objects,
we wanna be able to nuance
and get more specific
about what's actually in these objects.
So one of the things we can
do is we can sort of begin
the path down the road
towards transfer learning,
or retraining neural networks to be
more specific about what they find.
In this image we've
retrained the final layer of
a classification network
to tell us whether a car
is or is not a Volkswagen Beetle.
And you can see we get
really high accuracy on this,
this isn't sort of cherry picked.
This is a really great Beetle detector.
Now that's not actually
the most important thing.
What we wanna do is we wanna
take what we've learned about
semantic segmentation and the
ability to find objects in
an archive of hundreds of thousands of
black and white negatives,
and work with folks who
are really interested in the
urban history of Los Angeles
and the built environment.
We're interested in training
networks, to not find cars,
but to find perhaps art
deco in glass brick,
or the red tile of mission
revival architecture,
or maybe even the urban fabric of LA
in terms of its benches
for buses, its bodegas,
its laundromats and stores.
Even the vanishing amount of
single family bungalow houses
that were still present in the 1960s.
So that's an early glimpse into our
Every Pixel on the Sunset Strip
research collaboration with the Getty.
We have a brief page of
information about this
on our website, we look forward to putting
more information online soon.
Thanks so much.
(applause)
- Thank you very much, and last we have
Philip Corlett and Jane
Garrison presenting to us.
- Hi, my name's Phil Corlett,
I'm an associate professor
in the Psychiatry department,
and my work focuses on
how our brains create the
reality that we perceive,
and I'm particularly
interested in this term here,
psychosis, which is the
departure from contextual reality
that characterizes some
serious mental illnesses
like schizophrenia.
So believing things that don't pertain and
perceiving things that
aren't really there.
And the way that we understand
the symptoms is as this
sort of trade off for
attention between what
we've learned to expect about
our world through experience,
perhaps captured in
something like one those
convolutional neural networks
that we just heard about,
and then applying what we've learned to
what we're currently perceiving.
So as you see this rotating
mask of Charlie Chaplin's face,
something unusual may have happened.
The mask is rotating in
a clockwise direction and
continues to rotate like that,
however as you start to see
the inside of the face, your
very strong beliefs that
faces tend to be convex
rather than concave and that
light falls onto convex
rather than concave objects
in particular ways will drive
you to edit your conclusions
about what you're seeing.
And we think that's
what we do all the time
when we're navigating the world.
We think that people who
hallucinate in their everyday lives
may do that excessively.
Did you all see that?
So it's a pretty profound, I think,
example of how our learning
shapes what we see.
And in my lab we've tried
to sort of think about ways
in which computational
architectures might give rise to
that learning and how we
might model, if you like,
hallucinations and delusions in silico.
So you can imagine that your
brain is just a series of
sort of layers of neurons
interacting with one another,
sending predictions like face
point outwards, downwards,
and data going upwards
through the network.
And you can think about
sort of the trade offs
between those networks in terms
of predictions that are made
and prediction errors.
And the neural machinery in
your brain is really helping you
weight which thing to believe.
In the case of the hollow
mask, you're weighted towards
your very strong experience
in the world that
faces tend to point outwards.
And in my lab we try and pick apart
the neurochemical mechanisms
and neuro structural mechanisms
that give rise to these sorts
of mechanisms in order to
be able to perhaps better treat people
who suffer from delusions
and hallucinations.
But interestingly we can think about just
in a very simple way,
what might come about
if we perturb these networks.
So at the lowest levels we
might, if we over weighted
peoples' beliefs at the
lower levels of the network,
induced very simple, basic hallucinations,
the sorts of things that people
experience when they take
psychedelic, hallucinogenic
drugs for example.
And at higher doses of those drugs or
endogenous psychotic illness,
complex hallucinations
might come about when the
whole network is perturbed.
And you start to see new
objects cut out of whole cloth
appearing before our eyes our ears.
Let me see if I can show you this video.
So this is an example from
some colleagues at Sussex
who have taken Google
DeepDream and perturbed
the lowest levels of its
network, applying it now to
a video of the marketplace in Sussex.
And you can see these sort of
subtle geometric changes
that are happening.
So it looks sort of unusual
but not unintelligible,
and not entirely unexpected, it just looks
sort of low quality.
And like I said, these
sort of geometric patterns
seem to be the sorts of things
that people experience when
they take serotonergic hallucinogens
like LSD or psilocybin.
And just to show you now,
sorry.
What might happen when we make
the same sort of manipulation
to the highest levels of the network
whilst looking at the same video.
So now, the network has been trained on
lots of different photographs,
and it's inserting objects
into the video that really aren't there.
So you can see dogs, puffer fish,
eyes seem to be fairly commonly observed.
And so just taking this
sort of very simple
network architecture, we
can get some insights into
what might be happening, we
think, in the brains of people
who are on psychedelic drugs
and in the brains of people who
have psychotic illnesses.
And that's all well and good,
but there's nothing in there
or built into the network
that's really perceiving
what's sort of unusual
or uncomfortable about
what you just experienced.
Why does it feel so uncanny
or uneasy when your brain
edits the hollowed mask
and causes you to see
it switching direction,
and what would it mean if that
uncanniness or uneasiness
were not present.
And so with the digital humanities lab
and also some collaborations
at CCAM, we've been
thinking about ways in which
one might tether two of these
networks together in what's called
a generative adversarial network.
And the simple idea here is
that one side of one these
sort of convolutional neural nets might be
making suggestions about
what's out there in the world,
and another side might be
critiquing those suggestions
saying that they feel right
or they don't feel right
and rejecting them, and
that these two nets may be
training one another and
ultimately giving rise
to a sensation that, actually,
oh yes, that feels right,
or that feels wrong somehow.
And so that's what we've
been trying to explore.
These sorts of architectures
are currently being used
in the digital humanities
lab for various projects,
and what we're interested in
doing is partnering with folks
in digital humanities to
play around with these
network architectures, break
them, and see the ways in which
they break, see the ways in
which we might bias towards
generation of spurious
information, and see ways in which
we might disrupt the critic
in order to fool the generator
into believing what's
out there in the world
is radically different from reality.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you to all of
the speakers for these
amazing presentations and next
we want to make this more of
a discussion based, so we are
going to open up the floor
and if any of you have any questions about
any of these projects
or questions in general.
So I do want to have
like a leading question
just to open up, so all of
the speakers mentioned about
the application of like
data driven message
and the interdisciplinary
solutions, but what do you all
think is a good disciplinary
marriage in your
respective field between
data, art, humanities, law,
and what could potentially
be a bad marriage
or interdisciplinary solution?
- Well I think something that
is incredibly interesting,
and thank you for your
question, about that is don't go
in debate again that I
mentioned about in chronicles
about the fact that digital
humanities are a failure
because automated computing
calculation doesn't
work always in the arts.
And I think that the problem is that
the debate is not shaped
correctly somehow.
So a bad application of digital
humanities for literature
would be to expect the
computer to think for us.
Simply because it doesn't.
I mean automated car driving is not about
a car that is thinking,
it is about a car that is
reacting in every situation the
way it is supposed to react.
That is very different.
Since in literature we especially
want to do not over that,
like not to reproduce but
to say for something else.
And a good application is to
use it, and I think that goes,
that resonates with all the
talks, fascinating talks,
that have been given
there, is a new interface,
like new perception of
what we already know.
Is it a reality?
Giving access to people
by presenting something
in a different way than it is normally,
so opening the the access,
or to turn a book into
suddenly something else,
highlighting something else
in order either to communicate on this
or to give us new clues on new
ways to approach our objects,
so the question makes the
digital humanities relevant
or not, I would say.
- Sure, I'd like to add I think.
I see a lot of great
interdisciplinary work,
I see a lot of legal
research that's being done
in conjunction with other fields.
For example, we have
a cybersecurity course
at the law school, which is
almost purely cybersecurity
with very little law, because
if you're trying to make laws
about cybersecurity, maybe you should know
what cybersecurity actually is, right?
Like that's just something
that we lack a little bit
in law making, so I
think, if I think of maybe
a bad interdisciplinary
project, it would really just be
the lack of it in law and policy.
So you get a lot of laws and
you get a lot of policymakers
who don't understand technology,
or don't understand science,
or don't believe in science,
and this results in bad policy.
So that's a big problem.
And I'm glad that at least
in universities we're working
in interdisciplinary work
and hopefully we'll push that
forward as well, not just for government
but for industry too.
- So I think an example of
a bad collaboration would be
sort of falling between
two stools and not honoring
the sort of important
qualities of both sides
of an interdisciplinary project.
Sort of not being the best scientist
and not being the best artist.
In my own field, I think one
of the fears is if we try
and think about mental
symptoms in this way,
we rob them of their deep and important
sort of heritage and meaning for people,
and so I'd hate to see any approach
that we took to digitize the humanities
to forget that these sorts of
experiences, these artifacts,
these pieces of work are
beautiful in their own right,
and what I would hope is that
any interdisciplinary work
would enhance that rather
than detracting from it.
- Are there any audience
questions at this time?
Okay I can ask another.
So, when you first...
What inspired you to get into
this interdisciplinary field
and what inspired your, like,
introduction of digital methods
to your field of interest?
- Well I can say that I was inspired by
the digital humanities
staff, by Peter Leonard,
I was preparing a colloquium
on post-war magazines,
post-war cultural magazines and
we just started playing around.
And I didn't know anything
about the digital humanities
except having read Franco
Moretti's book on distant reading.
So I had some kind of
intuition about what what
we might be able to do that
an individual researcher
couldn't do just going through
the pages on a microfilm.
I mean, like everyone else I had
the nausea effect of reading microfilm.
But I think some of us are
doing digital humanities
without knowing it, we do
look inside to find a passage
when we're preparing a class on a book,
or we look at Google
Books, I mean it's already,
it's already there all around
us and what's great about
digital humanities is getting the culture
to formalize some of
these instinctive moods.
- So I actually have, part
of the reason why I started
working in interdisciplinary
sort of digital slash law
issues is because that's just what
I started doing during law school.
I'm right now leading an
initiative that's funded in part
by the Wikimedia foundation,
which is a nonprofit that's
run by Wikipedia, and I'm sure,
how many of you have used Wikipedia?
Pretty much everybody.
And I think that having
used those tools through my
education really led me
to want to work on them
and work on creating a world where
we could support those things.
So one thing I'd be really
interested in knowing
from all of you actually if
you don't mind me asking,
one of the topics that I work
is the idea of open access.
And I know for all us
open access scholarship
is a controversial issue.
Now how can we either get
our research out there
for the public, either
through open access journals
or through public scholarship,
whether or not you believe
public scholarship exists,
or other forms like that.
I'd be really interested in
hearing what you all think
about that and how we can kind
of move forward with bringing
a lot of the great
research at this university
out there to the public.
- I'll try and respond.
So, I agree it's absolutely sort of
essential that we make what
we work on and what we produce
openly available to the public.
I think what needs to change
in order to allow that
to happen is either for
journals to make that easier
or for our funding bodies
and institutions to
give us resources to make that happen.
And I don't see either of those
things happening immediately
without us being more vocal about
the fact that that's what we want.
When I write grants to
the National Institute of
Mental Health, for example,
I now build into the budgets and funding
in order to publish my work open access.
It's a different model in
the UK, you can't get funding
from the Welcome Trust or
the Medical Research Council
without committing to
publishing everything
that you have open access.
And they're much more further along
than we are in that regard.
So I think, you know, having
conversations like this
with people like yourself and
raising the profile of that
sort of issue is super important,
and being committed to it
and enacting that commitment
as much as possible.
- Yeah, maybe I would totally
agree, and I would add also
the way publications
basically are evaluated.
I'm thinking here for instance
of the difference between
publishing a critical
edition of a work in a book
with a publisher or online.
This is absolutely not the same weight
for a committee, for a resume.
So maybe there is also
things that could be done to
encourage the
open access publication.
Of course open access
doesn't mean necessarily
that it's not a journal, but
there is something there still.
- [Divek] Thanks for the answers there.
At this point...
Yes, thank you.
- Something I think is
connected to these things
you've been talking about in a
big way to the title even is,
so what happens later?
What are the ways to think about
unintended consequences of this research?
And unacknowledged fore
bearers of this research,
the surveillance state
and things like that.
How do these things come
into play in y'all's work?
- Can you elaborate what you mean by
the unacknowledged fore
bearers of the work?
- A lot of the, some
of the work comes from
entities that have used the algorithms
to detect political activity,
to target ads in biased ways,
things like that.
One argument could be that
using these in humanistic ways
is making a detour of those algorithms,
I'm sort of playing around in that area.
- I think it's a fascinating question
and I don't think there any
sort of straightforward answers.
I think the relationship between
something like psychology
and motivational decision
making and, you know,
entities like Google,
and Twitter, and Facebook
is tense to say the least.
I think the only way
that we can combat that
as academics and practitioners is to
highlight what's happening
and to make these mechanisms
as understandable and transparent
for the public as possible.
I don't think it would help
anyone if we turned our backs
on this and didn't study it more deeply.
That's certainly how I try and
handle things with my work,
which clearly has also sorts of
potential nefarious implications.
- I think that's really
a interesting question.
Some of my research has
been on privacy law,
and it gets into these issues.
So I have two quick things.
There's one project called the
All Of Us Program by the NIH
which seeks to collect the DNA
data of a million Americans
and use that for a public
database that can then, you know,
ideally generate great medical advances.
So this is an interesting
example, because here
you have clearly have a well
intentioned project that could
lead to breakthroughs in
precision medicine and more,
but the problem then is that
people don't really know
what's happening with their DNA data.
What does it mean when you
give your data to an entity
that then owns the data and
can do with it what it wants?
And there's a line in
legal scholarship about,
in law and medicine, about
consent to use of DNA samples
or blood samples in medical research.
For example, there's the
issue of whether or not
you have any ownership
stake in pharmaceuticals
that were developed
using research that had
used samples from certain people, right?
So there are these questions I think
that we have to deal with.
But more broadly speaking,
if you're just thinking about privacy,
I think there are a lot of
interesting techniques done
right now to protect privacy
so that data can be used
in these large data science projects.
I was recently at a privacy
security research event
at Google, which is one
company that people are
concerned about, obviously,
for privacy reasons.
But they have been
just really hiring a ton of
great academics for better or worse,
they're taking a lot of
great academics into industry
to work specifically on
privacy and security,
de-identifying data, how
to use federated learning
and other techniques to use the data
to find results without actually
being able to re-identify the data,
or being able to connect the
data to the data originator.
So there's work being done,
and a lot of it is interdisciplinary.
Again, with this sort of theme,
I think there is a lot that
could be done to help alleviate
what you're talking about.
- Thank for the question.
Are there, we can take about
two or three more questions,
does anyone have anything else to say?
Okay, yeah.
- I just have a follow up question
on what we mentioned already about.
So, so I think that one of the main,
some of the main purpose that
why we want to digitize things
or we want to visualize
things is either to
help researchers better on making some of
these breakthroughs on
the research, but also
on the other hand being able to present to
the general public,
making people understand
often some really complicated
scientific project.
But sometimes this is really a
balance, because for example,
like I grew up reading
Scientific American,
but then it presents certain
information in a way that
seems interesting but does
not necessarily follow
in the exact, like the
scientific rigorous process.
I'm wondering for many
of the researchers here,
how do you view that problem on digitizing
or visualizing some of
these like information,
because some of the critical information
could also lost in the
digitization process.
- Thank you for this terrific
question, I think, again,
sorry to get back to that, but yes,
that's one of the big thing
that digitizing is bringing
and is one of the least
discussed thing in a bizarre way.
We're on a screen so we can do things
that we couldn't do on paper.
And because probably of
some cultural background,
the visual is kind of
the, yeah, we'll see,
we'll figure out in the
end how we will show this,
the important is what
is behind, and in fact,
getting on the screen and
being able to do all the things
we can do with the screen and
showing things differently,
I think is one of the major assets of
any digitalization of any kind.
- So I work in brain
imaging, where we produce
maplike representations
of statistical tests
that make it appear as though
parts of the brain are lighting up
or are engaged by particular processes.
And there's been whole series of papers
almost cottage industries
of papers being exchanged,
the seductive allure of brain images,
the seductive allure
of seductive allure by
the people who don't
agree, and I think, again,
it gets down to being clear communicators.
Telling people that these aren't maps of
recorded neural activity, but
very circuitously generated,
statistically massaged,
visually doctored images
that represent statistical
tests nevertheless,
but helping people become
better consumers will
be more and more important
I think, as we go forward.
- So, we are seeking for one last question
from the audience maybe.
If anyone has, yes.
- This sort of gets back
to Peter's presentation,
but also I think many of them.
If you're thinking about
the visual in terms of
what we are now able to
render and what we will
be able to render in the
future, is that you're really
looking at something that
is completely nonlinear.
I'm an art historian and I'm also
an arts information manager,
or have been at a various
points in my life.
And one of the things that
has been deviling to me
aside from copywriting,
another symposium topic,
has been the fact that we often
come into the digital realm
prejudiced essentially by vocabulary.
And the ability to be able
to break out of that mold,
I think is truly transformational.
So the idea of neural
maps or nonlinearity,
any way that we can express the visual
without having to sort of predicate it
by calling it something,
that is expressed in words,
I think is really something
that we need to see
as very special, and I
would say is one of the
counterarguments I would
make to whatever was going on
from higher ed, which I would have to say
is one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard.
- That's a great comment.
I think that one of the things
that we're doing in the lab
in terms of writing reusable
software is to try to allow
people to work with cultural
heritage objects without
necessarily being beholden
to their textual description.
In the libraries in the the GLAM sector,
galleries, librarians,
libraries, and museums, archives,
we oftentimes really
prioritize, for good reason,
the textual description
of visual cultural.
We need to have an expert
look at this and determine
who the painter was and
where it was provenanced,
that's incredibly important work.
The Getty does this, YCBA does this.
But there are also new ways
of measuring visual similarity
or arranging collections at
the scale of 100,000 objects.
These purely on their kind
of the analysis of the
raster pixels, how they
look, and we, I think,
one of the things that's most
exciting to me in terms of
machine vision, in terms
of how computers see,
is the opportunity not to break
away from human description,
because human description
has within it decades
and centuries really of
expert provenance and
sort of connoisseurship,
but to put that human
textual description in conversation
with a kind of analysis
of the pixels themselves,
I think a lot of the work,
if those in the room have
seen the work of the lab
and Doug Duhaime in terms of PixPlot
and Neural Neighbors,
that's really exciting
open source software that
we hope to see deployed
in even more cultural institutions as an
alternate way of considering
the visual without having to
do something like look for
the word horse and miss
an image because it's
described as equestrian.
- Maybe if we could have more
questions from the audience,
if there is any?
Yes.
- So, I wanna ask, so there's
the digital and humanities
and when I think of those
two it reminds me of, like,
digital, like, you're
looking at sound wave
and how that's transferred
from a symphonic,
smooth current wave into a digitalized,
like, way that kind of cuts
out some of the nuances.
What do you think can be
lost possibly and how can you
protect that in the
transition in the marriage of
the synthesis between like the
digital and the humanities,
because as we were talking
about how the expert kind of is
ruling the kingdom here, and the expert is
traditionally kind of a
western white guy, and so
the language that kind of comes out of
that kind of expertise may overlook
the native capacity and the native morals,
so how might digital humanities benefit
from kind of expanding
the view of what an expert is,
and this was even mentioned in
an earlier work talking about
the value of expertise.
Like how would you speak to
the need to retain the norms
as we're transitioning into
these digitalized maps?
- I think it's a really
important question,
that's why I only listen
to music on vinyl,
to avoid any of that
quantization that will
just totally destroy the sound.
There's been really interesting
efforts there, there's,
I might mispronounce this, but
Mukurtu, which is an effort
to build a content management
system for the GLAM space
which is, originates more
in native understandings of
knowledge or restriction of knowledge
or empowerment of knowledge.
That's something I think
a lot of folks including,
I just got back from Australia
where people are really
thinking about that in
the aboriginal context
or a Strait Islanders context.
The great thing, the wonderful
thing and the horrible thing
about the digital is
that, you know, you can
build whatever you want with it.
So if you want a system that
will replicate existing systems
of knowledge control you
can do that, you can also do
sort of liberative or sort
of transcendent approaches
that liberate information or
present it in different ways.
I do think it's a fascinating
question you asked about
the notion of the
quantization or the reduction.
I think its the responsibility
of every human is to say,
does the particular
model I'm working with,
whether that's ASCII or Unicode,
whether that's 8-bit color
or 24-bit color, a vinyl or
CD, you know it's inherently
gonna be a model of the truth.
And so the question is, the
thing people heard a lot
is all models are wrong,
some of them are useful.
So you as a humanist have
to decide is the model
I'm working with, you know,
the parallel of the GAN versus
the human sort of schizophrenia,
is that a useful model,
you know, for your
particular research quest?
- Thank you so much for
this fascinating question,
and if I may, just a quick story,
because, yes, quantization is
breaking some kind of nuances,
but if you add enough information maybe
you can get even more nuance.
What I mean by that is I'm
working on early modern books,
and early modern books are
by definition hard to find.
And I did my PhD in Switzerland
where there were not as much
early modern French book as in Paris.
So for a long time everybody
doing a PhD in Switzerland
on early modern French
literature had to work on only
some authors just because there was only
modern editions of them existing.
So it was basically white males' work.
Right, when I started my PhD I was able
to access Google Books.
So suddenly, there was a whole
lot of books that weren't
available except if you
were living in Paris.
To me, here in Switzerland,
or to anyone, and also
a whole new lot of authors
and the texts were not only
available like the text, but in a
photographic reproduction of the page.
So a lot of things that were reserved
to a very specific elite before,
were available to the entire world.
I am putting big quotes here, but,
we understand what we are saying there.
So suddenly a lot of new
authors came into the field
and went back into the study,
and this expertise that was
previously reserved to
only just a few people
that were able to access these
book in the specific library,
were available and raised
new questions et cetera.
So, there is this kind
of, we can speak about,
yeah but we don't access the
actual book, and it's true
and at the same time
through this quantization,
we open the access in a
very different way, so.
- Just a further comment on
the ideas of reductionism
and models and that really beautiful
George Box quote about usefulness.
We learned a lot about
how airplanes can fly by
making balsa wood wings and
placing them in a wind tunnel,
and we never got mad at
ourselves that we couldn't
cram our luggage into that
wing and take off and leave,
like we're not aiming for
complete descriptions,
we're aiming, well ultimately
we want a complete description
but our pathway there
is breaking things down
and putting them back together again.
And I think that's what
we're all engaged in.
- Thank you again,
that's a great question.
I think a lot about the
issues of knowledge equity
and, you know, who is
considered an expert.
This is something that is kind of an issue
for Wikipedia right now,
working on a sort of strategy
for the next few decades.
If you've ever tried to edit
Wikipedia you have come into
knowledge it's actually not that easy.
So you can try to edit,
but if you, for example,
add something without a
reference, it'll get deleted.
Or if your reference is
deemed not expert enough,
or not legitimate enough you
might get deleted as well.
So this is a problem because
there are whole communities
around the world that, for example,
don't have the same idea of expertise.
Maybe their knowledge
is mostly oral history,
maybe they don't have as many
written records as we do.
So it's a question for the
Wikipedia right now, and for,
I'm sure, all of us, about
how we look at those types of
knowledge and how we evaluate
who gets to be an expert
in the room, who gets to sit
on a panel at Yale University
talking about what knowledge is, right?
We don't have anyone from those
communities who may not have
the benefits of multiple
degrees from fancy universities
in order to talk about these things.
And if they're not in
the conversation then
their knowledge is lost and
knowledge doesn't get to them.
So that's something I think
we have to think about
a lot as well too.
- Thank you for your
question and thank you
for the wonderful responses.
I'd like one last applause
for our round table speakers.
(applause)
and I'd like to invite Susan Gibbons up
to give closing remarks.
- Good afternoon everyone,
I'm Susan Gibbons
and I have the honor of being
Yale's University librarian
and Deputy Provost for Collections
and Scholarly Communication.
It's also been my pleasure
to have been able to attend
these conferences, this is now our fourth,
and therefore can comment on
the arc of the conferences
and how they have changed over time.
Initially, with our first
conference we had a lot of
speakers from the outside.
We brought them in to help
get the conversation started.
Today we're able to fill the
room and fill the program
with conversations from
inside of Yale, because
we've come so far and there's
so many robust projects
to be talked about.
If you look at the program
today we had speakers who are
undergraduates, graduate
students, faculty, and librarians,
and I'd say there aren't too
many conferences that happen
on campus that have that
mix within that program.
Similarly if you look
at the disciplines that
were represented, math,
data science, law, French,
engineering, music,
psychiatry, and many more.
Again, where else do we have
these kinds of opportunities
where we can talk across
disciplines and talk
in meaningful ways that
we can actually connect
across the different disciplines?
We started this conference as a way
to cause these conversations to happen.
To help share the fact that
there were common methods
and tools and data acquisition methods
and methods for demonstrating
and visualizing our findings,
that they were happening
throughout various disciplines,
but you weren't always recognizing them.
And so what we wanted this
conference to do was to
give an opportunity to share
ideas, to share projects,
and realize that you actually
have an intellectual partner
that's somewhere across this
campus that can form a network
essentially to help you move
forward with your projects.
And so I think we have done that.
The last piece I'll observe though is
in our early conferences
it was a speaker presenting
on a project, one after
another, which was wonderful.
But we weren't yet ready to
have the kinds of conversations
we just had with this panel.
That we could actually
have the kind of discussion
that we did that goes
beyond the technology
and goes beyond the
techniques and asks some of
the deeper questions that
regardless of discipline
we all need to be thinking about.
And that's a maturation of
the conversation here at Yale
that is just so wonderful
to see and experience.
So we will continue to
try to bring together
these conversations and invite even
a wider and wider audience to participate.
So before we transition
to our poster session,
which will be right next door,
I wanna thank our different sponsors.
We have Yale STEAM, Yale Code4Good,
Yale's Digital Humanities Lab, and
the Yale Poorvu Center
for Teaching and Learning.
Throughout the day they
have contributed in
many different ways and
so if you would join me
in a round of applause for our sponsors.
(applause)